Hawaii this island paradise is one of
the most beautiful states in the Union
it's also the most reliably democratic
in 2012 President Barack Obama won the
state by a massive 42 percentage points
more than in any other state
Hawaii is such a Democratic stronghold
that its state Senate has only a single
sitting Republican an island on an
island who has the spacious minority
caucus room all to himself this is the
loneliest man in the Senate Aloha I'm
state senator Sam Slom I'm the leader of
the Senate minority in the Hawaii State
Legislature they refer to me as a lone
ranger but that's a good thing because
the lone Ranger's a good guy after the
election I started getting phone calls
sympathy messages and sympathy cards
about oh my gosh it's so sad that you're
the only one and as it turned out I had
my research staff look in the last 50
years this is the only example of a
single person of a major political party
of being in their house or their Senate
it's had many benefits first of all I
didn't have anybody trying to topple me
as a Minority Leader being a good
conservative libertarian it is an
individual that can do good things or
not-so-good things or whatever I'll be
sitting in a committee waiting to vote
and a committee clerk will come from
next door and say senator Slom senator
Slom we need you for a quorum whenever
there's a problem discovered or whatever
I'll go to the majority leadership and
tell them hey you know I know you're
gonna pass this bill I don't have the
votes to stop it obviously but you might
want to consider improving the bill and
passing a good bill frustrating to me is
the fact that normally they'll say yeah
fine we'll pass the bill this year we'll
come back next year and fix it my first
Senate speech ever was to my colleagues
when we had two Republicans at that time
I probably are not going to be able to
influence your votes most of the time
although I'll try but my point here is
I'm going to raise issues and talk about
unintended consequences so that years
later you will not have the luxury of
saying oh is that what that bill meant
is that what that does at least we'll
all know and you'll know why you're
voting forward or voting against it it's
interesting because the history of
which of course at one time was a
monarchy and then became a territory
Republicans ruled Hawaii completely for
50 years during territorial days and
then for the next 60 years it's been the
Democrats that have ruled completely
here's the thing
things are changing they're changing all
the time with the death of senior
senator Daniel Inouye last December who
had been in office for 54 years there
were generations that knew no one else
but him
there were even Republicans if they
wanted something done they went to Dan
Inouye he was the go-to it guy but now
he's gone and so some of the positions
that he blocked and some of the people
that he helped now there's more
independence of that Hawaii has been
positioned for a long time to take
advantage of you know outside investment
venture capital we could be a you know a
Singapore or a Hong Kong but we choose
not to because we have a long tradition
of government and government involvement
the basic change is going to come in
education we have charter schools as
part of the public school system I think
it's incumbent upon everyone
particularly people with children but
also people in business to be involved
in the schools of all the things that
you can do to be a change agent it's
educational choices I mean that's what
Milton Friedman stressed in Hawaii one
of the problems is we're 2,500 miles in
the middle of the ocean here unlike
other places on the mainland where you
could downsize if things got rough you
could move to you know a smaller
community or to another county or if you
had to cross the state lines in a way
basically you're here or you're not here
people want to be here but it's
expensive to be here and politically
it's expensive also
I am very supportive of the idea that we
can make changes here because if we
don't the the downside to all this is
being so far
in the Pacific the state will be far
lonelier than I am as the lone
Republican in the Senate